okay and welcome to this video this is
Grand Master dr. John none here playing
with black against me and we probably do
we get the Kings Indian probably but I
can't try something else let's try for
double-a in shantou are usually go for
main lines against him but why not
change pace a little bit okay that's
that's a line that i really like ever
have an excellent score there with white
in tournament chess so how am I going to
play it I can't play other various ideas
I like you can go with D for you can
play like that I went Quincy to to make
sure that be too is protected oh it's
like this kind of approach I think that
this is a good way to keep a very slight
advantage white some pawn structure
simply a little bit more more active
here it's um yeah it's nothing nothing
particularly great but it is okay white
can often play on the C file somewhere
so I went rogue c1 or play b4 b5 yes
Bishop h3 now which is a bit a bit
worrisome okay d for an interesting move
ok cutting off my bishop they're only
five but it has enough pieces to take
that's a very interesting approach
okay so i have to take them basically
and now back to you one okay interesting
very interesting position yes pressure
there on the issue upon
but what about this if I go here and for
before before looking at the default
pawn let's see d4 pawn now is kind of
isolated yeah if it takes on f3m I'm
quite happy so maybe queen bee to hear
right there's no tech check & I'm not
sure if I'm very threatening d for that
sets one problem okay he seems to
believe I'm attacking it a bit high I
cannot really increase the pressure on
that poem okay is going back interesting
it's kind of difficult to go from here
maybe I should still do this like a 45
ok Knight e5 is probably not doing much
let's go up here interesting f4 I
thought you had to react to a 6 but he
didn't have 95 now isn't that good I
thought that it's just good as he thinks
is a big problem he's in Monster fork
them I thought he had to play a 6
what is my score against him anyway
fifty percent okay always have
interesting games I recently remember I
game that I wanted from a completely
losing position due to some silly tactic
so yeah let's check taken first yeah one
issue is said and he has this cell this
is a very um yeah that's a serious
counterplay sorry how do I am how do I
make sure f4 is not so dangerous
something will see 5 maybe see how is
going to play b5 my rocks are not doing
that much this is a problem here if afro
kingi to something like that and yeah at
least I have rook h1 which activates one
rook methods is not this is not so easy
it's not so easy to play ok I'm going to
going to get a passer here or if he
takes it i'm open this whole thing opens
up for my rooks I was a pawn and an
exchange app so i don't mind to to ditch
a pawn here
it takes it what am I going to do Queen
B 7 I was really not considering this so
much because I felt like opening up the
position should be should be good anyway
so maybe yeah that's a negative most
active looking at least still my rooks
are not not doing much really have to
admit that look be one look p7 as an
idea
and it's a temper of course push up a
three King h2 with no problem right Sam
go for that
yeah it looks fairly safe I don't don't
see a super dangerous counterplay at the
moment and they have recruit b7 coming
check
yeah Queenie five I thought is pretty
good for Bishop g5 check looks highly
irritating for black like I've got 55
Noah Bishop g5 Bishop e6 check its Ruby
eight good now let's check this time
morning rook b8 Queen v8 Bishop e6 the
ad looks that looks strong I can also
take I can also just take him check yeah
that's that's easy actually Queen takes
check check check a couple of times
check so the ship on c3 doesn't matter
any 0 e to hangs but is this important
just to check out it's just a check
check okay for something check Stifel
mate if he comes up
check black resigns hmm yeah interesting
it was interesting game he just
overlooked the 95 move yeah very very
interesting kind of um yeah structural
transpositions here the deform was very
interesting he m yeah plays against this
Bishop there which looks nice but it can
easily turn out to be yeah without moves
like here Knight g4 as an idea the
bishop doesn't have any move so i went
to take it and went for rookie won the
honesty of thought I'm bit in trouble
here because of the e porn but it didn't
turn out to be that that problematic and
this before normal Queen B to you know I
think I think actually this is all ok in
some way five yeah f5 is already yeah
giving me five for the moment but it's
not a problem yet but here I thought he
just has to either play a six yeah
preventing any anything like my a six or
just drop the bishop back also possible
the bishop wouldn't be barely placed him
but the way it went I think a six should
be should be quite good yeah he had
overlooked 95 entirely um fickle was
like something Queen Queen movie it's
still not that that bad of course that
wasn't what he wanted nobody goes for
this kind of structural problem
voluntarily but this is still quite
quite playable this is maybe even
interesting like here here after this a
continuity for very complicated
and after this I'm essentially winning
it's just a metal check good technical
play I guess f5 I think this is okay f4
kingi to this is just for for security
and now I did should see five hmm what
why is the engine giving equal this is a
queen g5 interesting now I didn't see
that idea really only that Quincy five
for Bishop f4 I am okay that makes c5
dubious dubas choice you have to go rook
h1 yeah of course i mean i can't play
that c5 move anyway I mean at any point
and maybe this is just better getting
first some defensive resources in so you
went here I can't still do that and now
Queen g 5y after that I'm winning but
here yeah this is strong yeah it's just
wrong can you do here here and then the
engine wants to do this so after Bishop
takes King f1 that that's already a bit
shaky for what engine gives 000 seeing
some perpetual but yeah so he had he had
his chances but I think I hope I just
after that I didn't allow anything check
I saw Luke p8 but I thought okay Chad it
just winds chance quite come to back and
turn yeah it does ok interesting game he
still had chances even after the blunder
so always continue to fight ok well
thanks for watching